[Musique]
chère
sale puttin à fesse de
singe tu es vraiment une foutue
dépravé et tu es aussi une triste
je crois que ce n'est que de la
jalousie je pense que nous savons qui
c'est
je je suis innocente je crois que nous
avons peutêtre accusé une inoc une femme
agent de policeez un cochon
Volantis mal camarades en prison oh pas
des meurtriers ou des violeurs je
pensais plutôt à des ivrognes ou des
déviants par
exemple sal veillant pas fait face de
chouette de menteuse à la
con pourquoi j'écrirai ce que je peux
dire en
face je pourrais dire que tu ressembles
à cette de reine Victoria qui se
serait Fouré une de poignet
d'orti au fond de sa de chatte
par exemple tu sens le et la
merde et des gâteaux que tu fais on leur
tout droit sorti du trou du cul d'
mouton c'est mieux
ça j'ai un
plan de Mar mon mari est plus env alors
il pense plus
grandchose je t'aime bien
rose pas rester les bras
[Musique]
crois
parir